37 year old Grafton Thomas faces five
counts of attempted murder after an
attack at a Hanukkah party in Muncie New
York a witness called the attack
terrified the swinging is a war knife I
don't know what it was back and forth
hitting people you didn't say anything
you screamed after me when they came out
here he's coming after me hey you I'll
get you but that's it that's about it so
far
Thomas has not been charged with a hate
crime the New York State Governor says
the suspect should get that and more I
think this is an act of terrorism
I think these are domestic terrorists
they are trying to inflict fear they're
motivated by hate they are doing mass
attacks these are terrorists the Montse
attack is the latest in a series of
assault on Jewish Americans this year
New York City police say that as of
December 15th 213 anti-semitic hate
crime complaints have been filed this
year
that's 36 more than in 2018 eight of
those attacks have happened in the last
couple of weeks including a woman and
her son attacked while leaving a coffee
shop in nearby Jersey City three people
were murdered in a kosher supermarket on
December 10th while police are
increasing neighborhood patrols and some
Israeli politicians say it might be time
for Jewish Americans to leave the u.s.
others saying it will take much more
than law enforcement to fight
anti-semitism we believe that this time
even more than ever
educational efforts with regard to the
Holocaust Remembrance and the fight
against intensity anti-semitism is more
needed but right now people are scared
and the priority is keeping people safe
Russel and Jordan al Jazeera Washington